we have uh charles from btcs who's gonna
be joining us here in a second charles
is uh today making a huge announcement
uh for their business they're a publicly
traded company on nasdaq they trade
under the ticker btcs uh i believe and
they have announced that they are going
to be the first publicly traded company
in history to issue a corporate dividend
that can be paid either in dollars or in
bitcoin so let's bring charles on and
charles how are you i'm good anthony
thanks so much for having me absolutely
let's jump into uh this bitcoin dividend
first of all how do you pronounce the
word it's not a dividend it's a dividend
is that what yeah
all right it's a dividend help me
understand uh the process uh of your guy
or your thought process in terms of why
you guys are doing this no corporation
in the public markets has ever done this
before so why are you guys doing this
it's something we've wanted to do for a
while so we actually went public in 2014
um
you know we didn't have the financial
resources to do something like this then
we bought the domain dividend dot com in
20 early 2015
and you know so why we're doing it now
um you know if we just put out a new
corporate deck and we talked a little
bit about our business
but you know as of the end of you know
last year december 31st 2021
our you know cash and crypto based on
fair market value per share is 356 and
we're trading at three dollars right so
that gives zero value to
any of the the the operations that we
have the 1.2 million we did in revenue
uh on audited for 2021. um what we're
doing it was just we kind of scratched
our heads and said this is ridiculous
right we need to we need to take some
action
and
uh so the timing was perfect and so you
know the board decided to pay a you know
five cent per share uh dividend or if
you want it in bitcoin it's a dividend
so you know it's a way to reward our
loyal shareholders and create interest
uh in our company and hopefully bring
some some you know eyeballs onto what
we're actually building here um so
that's that's kind of how we how we got
there okay so this is a really important
point just on the assets on the balance
sheet that comes out if you take the
total assets on the balance sheet
divided by the number of outstanding
shares that's the equivalent of about
three dollars and 50 cents or so uh if
i'm understanding this correctly the
stock was trading at three dollars a
share give or take and so
people were valuing your business
less than the assets on the balance
sheet which already right if you're a
value investor out there uh news flash
maybe you want to take a look is that
like how you guys were thinking about
this
exactly look we one of the problems we
have is
and i'm sure you know this you've talked
to other ceos of you know public
companies is that we hold crypto at the
lowest price it's ever been since the
data acquisition right if it drops below
our purchase price we mark it down so
the the value on our balance sheet is
showing up at 13 million that's
consistent with u.s gaap the fact is
that's not based on market prices that's
that's the lowest price it's ever been
so we have 20 million of unrealized
gains that don't show up in our
financial statements
right we paid off 2 million in debt in
2021 because we could it was convertible
debt we didn't want to take the dilution
you know that was a you know in our eyes
a very good corporate action to
you know
kind of
minimize
you know dilution to our shareholders
and
it's still the stock came down so you
know this was an action that we thought
would you know hopefully kind of you
know bring the market to understand and
realize that you know there's a lot of
value to our company right and if you if
you don't even value us at the you know
the assets we hold like what's going on
right it's uh you know i think we're one
of the most exciting areas when it comes
to the business model which we haven't
even touched on so you know it just
seemed like uh from a timing perspective
it was the right time okay so i think
that makes sense now in terms of how
this is operationally going to work you
guys have an entire website
bedividin.com i went i wrote about it
this morning i went deep into the weeds
trying to understand this thing uh and
what it appears like is there's
basically three core components to it
the first is it's five cents in u.s
dollar terms you're going to determine
how much bitcoin that ends up being on
march 16th of 2022 right so whatever the
date uh whatever the price of bitcoin is
on that day that's what uh bitcoin
you're gonna get that's equivalent to
five cents per share the second thing
that people have to do is you have to
opt into the bitcoin so the default is
dollar denominated five cent dividend if
you opt into bitcoin then you get
bitcoin and not cash and then the third
thing is they essentially as part of
that opt-in process give you a wallet
address and once you've confirmed that
yes this is the shareholder and the
wallet address that you sync them
together when you go to pay out you'll
pay some out in dollars some of it
you'll pay out in bitcoin to those
wallet addresses is that generally how
this works
that that's basically it except for one
piece okay i missed something over what
i mess up so shareholders need to be
record holders right like if you just
like the whole stock market is somewhat
broken the way it works today meaning
that if you're a shareholder of my
company i don't know who you are you may
be an objecting shareholder so you can
your broker won't tell me who you are so
you need to move your shares to the
transfer agent uh and we're gonna pay
for that process both moving the shares
to and back so you're gonna have to fill
out a form contact your broker you move
them over then we know who you are right
uh otherwise there's no way for us to
know who our shareholders are it's just
unfortunate how how the process works at
which point you know that that was the
only piece you missed uh we're looking
at in the future of ways we could do
this where it would be blockchain based
for this one we just wanted to you know
get something done given you know where
our uh you know where our stock was
trading compared to the
you know the assets and the value that
we believe the company has okay now what
is the response been already we're only
a couple hours into this thing right
three four five hours whatever it is
since you guys announced it what's the
response been in terms of you guys doing
this are shareholders pissed are they
excited uh have you got calls from
regulators like what's going on so far
um you know we haven't any calls from
regulators i mean as part of the process
we you know we called the sec um you
know months ago and just just to get
their feel on you know how they would
react uh we submitted everything ahead
of time to the nasdaq uh yesterday and
today we haven't any you know um haven't
heard anything from them so i don't
think there's an issue and you know as
far as investors go i mean hopefully
this this brings light to the you know
the business model because that's what
we're most excited about right um what
we're building what we're you know
what's there you know the assets is kind
of a nice to have um
but uh you know so far just looking at
the stock you know it's up substantially
um i think you know on a volume basis 25
million shares have traded so far i mean
that's i wouldn't have expected that but
obviously people are looking at it and i
hope when investors look at the company
they really look at the business model
because that to me is the most
compelling aspect of what we're doing
you know paying out a five cent you know
dividend in bitcoin is great but like
you know we have a strong balance sheet
we can do it look at what we're building
right it's really exciting